[Musique]
bien nous sommes au de l'Atmos on est
pratiquement chez vous Mustapha alors
oui nous sommes au lacmos à
l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et alors on va
parler évidemment de l'espace de
l'inspire 7 qui a été lancé avec succès
le 15 avril dernier et puis on verra
peut-être tout à l'heure il va peut-être
passer au dessus de Guyancourt avec avec
l'autre satellite que vous avez lancé il
y a combien 3 ans
2021 donc il y a un peu plus de 2 ans et
oui tout à l'heure
vers 11h c'est vrai qu'on va avoir un
événement intéressant c'est qu'on va
avoir
uvsq7 qui passera et qui va télécharger
ces données et il va être suivi
d'INSPIRE sat donc vous allez voir les
deux satellites qui vont se croiser au
dessus de nos têtes et qui vont vider
leurs données ça va être génial et puis
on va parler évidemment donc des
satellites que vous avez que vous avez
envoyé des raisons pour lesquelles les
envoyer et d'ailleurs vous venez
d'écrire un livre qui s'appelle l'espace
et le SP au service du climat c'est
exactement la fonction des deux
satellites satellites de VSQ et inspire
ça que vous avez envoyé voilà là
j'explique globalement pourquoi on
s'intéresse à ces satellites qui sont
des outils pour nous l'objectif c'est ce
n'est pas de lancer des satellites pour
lancer des satellites mais pour leur
donner une utilité notamment pour
pouvoir mieux comprendre et observer
depuis l'espace notamment la planète la
planète et on verra tout à l'heure c'est
ça que les satellites va vous envoient
des données que vous que vous récoltez
après que vous interprétez et qui vont
servir évidemment justement dans l'étude
du réseau pour lesquelles par exemple il
dit à ce réchauffement climatique dont
on souffre aujourd'hui exactement dans
ce livre aussi vous parlez de aussi de
l'histoire de la conquête spatiale de
l'histoire de l'espace peut-être qu'on
peut aller regarder quelques objets non
on peut aller voir quelques objets vous
montrer un maillot alors oui on
s'intéresse évidemment à la conquête
spatiale parce que tout le monde parle
en ce moment de ce que ce qu'on appelle
le new space c'est cette nouvelle forme
de la constipation qui est portée par
les acteurs majeurs du spatial comme
Elon Musk
alors nous l'inspiration on l'a trouvé
plutôt dans le spatial français à ses
origines celui qui a été mis en place
dans les années 1950 oui parce que on
est très bon on a été très beau alors
moi j'aurais tendance à dire la France
c'est quand même une grande puissance
spatiale alors c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de décrire dans ce petit t-shirt facile
à regarder on va le montrer comme ça
alors ici on a fait une petite affiche
rétro-futuriste justement pour faire une
projection vers l'avenir donc vous voyez
qu'ici on voit une voiture célèbre c'est
une Citroën ça pourrait être celle du
général de Gaulle puis une petite
immatriculation de 1962 on voit un
moment la naissance la naissance de
l'agence spatiale française voilà et
ensuite on a une fusée alors au départ
il y avait des petites fusées les
premières fusées françaises s'appelait
Véronique c'est celle qui ont été mises
en orbite dans les années 1950 Véronique
et les suivantes diamants elles avaient
des noms de De de de petits objets
précieux donc diamant qui est en orbite
et ici vous voyez typiquement ce qu'on a
représentait aussi c'est la découverte
de la turbopose c'est une des couches de
l'atmosphère donc au travers de cette
image on s'inspire du passé pour
imaginer le futur et là typiquement on
voit une dame
française qui regarde un panneau et qui
dit vers une armée de cubsac pour le
climat donc on se projette à l'horizon
2030 et ce qu'on dit c'est un moment
avoir une multitude de petits satellites
qui vont permettre de sonder l'état de
l'atmosphère de la planète pour pouvoir
essayer de trouver des solutions et là
on met nos deux petits satellites qui
sont orbites un peu plus haut donc ça
donne un peu une idée donc une t-shirt
avec l'histoire un peu de l'espace et
c'est très intéressant ce que on en
reparlera peut-être mais vous dites il y
a la Citroën voilà la DS de Gaulle
peut-être ça pourrait être ça et et
c'est vrai que là on est dans dans les
années 60 enfin 1962 hein et et
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu une volonté
politique au départ une volonté forte
dès la fin des années 1950 pour pouvoir
avoir un accès à l'espace et ensuite
avoir la capacité d'avoir des lanceurs
pour mettre en orbite on voit ici
quelques lanceurs et ensuite la aussi
une volonté d'avoir un satellite
opérationnel juste une petite info le
premier satellite français qui s'appelle
Astérix il a été mis en orbite en 1965
avec un lanceur français depuis la base
algérienne à l'époque donc en Algérie ah
oui et oui oui donc c'était c'était
pourtant après l'indépendance de
l'Algérie 65 exactement
cette volonté française qui fait que bah
on a eu aussi beaucoup de nous on
appelle des spationaute c'est ça
on va dire un spationaute les Américains
vont dire un astronaute pour le
soviétique
c'est vrai que on est une des
avec évidemment il y a eu il y a eu la
lutte entre les États-Unis et
la guerre froide il fallait courir
l'espace il y avait et puis c'était il y
avait une question de prestige voilà
quand quand Gagarine part quoi se garer
c'est 57 à peu près exactement c'est ce
qu'on appelle un peu plus tard parce que
1957 vous avez Sputnik et le premier
satellite qui est mis en orbite puis à
la fin des années 50 début d'année 1960
nous avons Youri Gagarine qui devient le
premier homme dans l'espace donc
par rapport même au passé avec
certaines histoires qui racontent des
personnes qui ont essayé de voler c'est
très tôt on voit cette envie de voler et
de s'extraire de l'atmosphère
et donc là alors on a toute une série de
maquettes
qui nous raconte un peu bah cette
conquête de l'espace cette conquête et
puis surtout pour nous c'est comment on
peut à un moment avoir un système qui va
nous permettre de mettre en orbite un
satellite donc pour mettre en orbite un
satellite il nous faut un lanceur alors
nous le rêve c'est du côté d'Ariane
Ariane évidemment nous on se dit mais
bon
escu et le Latmos qui sont à Guyancourt
pourquoi ils vont ils vont ils vont vers
le séparer le musk
la particularité c'est la disponibilité
des lanceurs et ensuite la capacité
d'avoir un moment une date de lancement
au moment où on doit mettre en orbite
notre satellite alors j'insiste nous on
souhaitait partir avec rien
pour des raisons de calendrier ou de
disponibilité ça ne s'est pas fait alors
petit parallèle aussi par rapport à cela
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'autonomie
stratégique ce qui est fondamental c'est
que la France et l'Europe dispose de
moyens de lancement ça c'est fondamental
donc en ce moment la situation est
compliquée mais il faut rester optimiste
ça va un moment revenir dans l'ordre
voilà et puis une petite parenthèse
historique pour cette fusée l'Agence
spatiale européenne est créée en 1973
avec un moment la volonté de mettre en
place ce programme Ariane avec la
première Ariane qui a des collants 1979
et juste aussi une petite parenthèse
pour l'histoire nous avons un satellite
qui est parti le 15 avril 2021 avec le
lanceur de Elon Musk SpaceX Falcon nine
mais le 14 avril Ariane 5 a mis en
orbite
la sonde juice juice c'est parti donc
qui est quand même une excellente
mission de l'Agence spatiale européenne
je vais vous poser une question très
bête de me dire que je suis absolument
idiot mais pourquoi les filles ont cette
forme là parce que ça rend plus
facilement dans l'espace c'est une
question de format aérodynamique c'est
un objectif c'est de pouvoir à un moment
aller vers le haut et pouvoir se séparer
alors si vous les vissez vous allez voir
il y a deux étages aussi c'est pas
difficile
de casser toutes les premières étage et
deuxième étage c'est ce qu'on appelle la
coiffe et à l'intérieur de la croix
c'est celui qui va se positionner à une
certaine altitude pour pouvoir mettre en
orbite les satellites d'accord ah oui
donc les satellites sont
là dedans c'est ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle la coiffe la coiffe la coiffure
et donc ça ça se sépare au bout de
combien de temps
ça dépend des lanceurs on pourra
reprendre le cas là de SpaceX pour la
suivi et expliquer un peu le lancement
alors donc ça c'est Ariane et il y aura
probablement enfin on va pas on va pas
on va pas tout dévoiler mais mais
probablement qu'un jour il y aura il y
aura un salaire de lovinski de l'Atmos
qui sera annoncé
un tir avec Ariane 6 là qui est en cours
de développement ou bien un vegacé dans
une nouvelle version
alors
celle-ci celle-ci alors vous pouvez y
aller alors je peux la prendre alors ça
c'est c'est quelque chose qui a fait
rêver beaucoup de monde là vous avez
la conquête de l'espace par l'homme quoi
alors c'est c'est Saturne 5 qui est a
permis de mettre le premier homme sur
sur la Lune en 1969 Neil Armstrong et
ses compatriotes et là vous avez la plus
grosse fusée qui a été développée à
l'époque dans le cadre du programme
Apollo alors récemment vous avez vu
aussi le vote
on l'a vu après coup la branche me
souviens moi je l'avais vu à l'époque en
classe là de de on l'avait vu en décalé
en différé et ça nous avait marqué quoi
on avait trouvé ça génial évidemment et
et
je crois ça fait partie vous savez des
des dates comme ça dans l'histoire on se
souvient où on était à ce moment-là et
je pense que tout le monde se souvient
où était je crois que c'est le 14
juillet
le 21 juillet 21 juillet 1969 exactement
tout le monde se souvient où il était ce
soir là et on va regarder il y avait
regardé à la télévision enfin il y avait
des images qui sont arrivés quoi c'était
c'était c'était la première fois qu'un
homme marcher sur la lune quoi ouais
c'est quelque chose bon nous on voit que
j'expliquais moi j'étais dans le nord de
la France en classe de CP la première
fois que j'avais revu l'événement
j'avais un enseignant qui s'appelait
monsieur oud je m'en souviens aussi et
puis ça ça m'a marqué mais on était plus
dans l'actualité donc on aurait aimé
vivre ce direct quoi c'est pour ça que
ce sont des événements qu'on essaie de
revivre et cette conquête spatiale avec
ses moyens cette nouvelle frontière a
voulu à la base par Kennedy à la base
absolument là aussi il y a une volonté
politique il y avait ce que ce que
disait tout à l'heure il y a aussi la
guerre froide à l'époque donc il y avait
aussi cette cette volonté aider des
Américains d'un côté et des Russes de
l'autre de dominer l'espace enfin et des
Français qui s'en servent dans cette
espace avec les uns et les autres
exactement on a su puisqu'il y a eu des
il y a eu des qui sont partis avec les
Américains et qui sont partis avec les
Russes et même je crois qu'il y en a un
qui est parti avec les deux peut-être
parmi là il a il a fait il était numéro
2 dans un programme et numéro 1 avec les
avec les Russes donc ça c'est ça c'est
alors c'est ça c'est lequel c'est
Saturne alors là vous avez ici Saturne 5
et là c'est pareil alors si vous
regardez vous avez ici alors ici on a un
petit Lego qui permet de le voir donc
vous avez un étage et ici regardez
deux étages vous êtes trois étages trois
étages
on regarde quand le premier étage
pourquoi vous êtes sur trois étages donc
c'est le premier qui c'est pas c'est
celui-là exactement et donc regardez ça
vous fait quand même un premier étage
vous avez un deuxième étage
[Musique]
c'est pas terminé regardez vous avez 3e
étage c'est pas fini et puis à
l'intérieur
vous avez la sauce de retour
vous avez l'atterrisseur lunaire
d'accord
ici vous avez l'atterrisseur lunaire et
à un moment vous allez avoir le petit
système qui va permettre aux humains de
revenir à un moment vers la terre on
récupère à ça après
tout de suite voilà donc ça donne et
après parce qu'on va vous parler de
perspective avec des Rover aussi
oui c'est ça parce que c'est il y a
ça montre un peu là la complexité d'un
modèle spatial d'un système spatial
c'est un moment d'ailleurs assez inouïe
le retour sur Terre et aussi
probablement dangereux enfin pas très
très dangereux tout toutes ces étapes
sont dangereuses et c'est ces éléments
c'est ce qui nous inspire c'est à dire
qu'à un moment on va chercher une source
d'inspiration alors ce qui s'est fait
dans le passé et très souvent vous avez
vu dès le début on vous a parlé de
newspace c'est à dire cette nouvelle
vision de la conquête spatiale bon nous
j'insiste on est en train de faire ce
qui se faisait dans le passé avec une
prise de risque ce qui existait dans le
passé c'est la prise de risque oui le
message qu'on peut envoyer aux jeunes
c'est il faut tenter j'insiste c'est
important de prendre des risques de
tenter et ensuite je l'ai dit
précédemment on va apprendre et ensuite
faut accepter potentiellement l'échec
pour mieux rebondir parce que en ayant
un échec un échec ça n'a pas de sens
c'est un apprentissage
alors
celle-ci faut la prendre Patrice c'est
c'est le lanceur de Space X Falcon 9
donc vous voyez c'est c'est une fusée
qui fait environ 70 mètres de haut
la fusée aérienne 5 c'est environ une
cinquantaine de mètres et le gros module
là de Saturne 5 on vient de démonter
c'est environ 110 mètres si vous
regardez le Starship qui est parti
récemment c'est environ 130 mètres c'est
la plus grosse fusée qui a décollé
quelques jours auparavant depuis Boca
Chica au Texas
cet échec mais
c'était comme vous dites il faut
accepter l'échec c'est aussi une façon
de concevoir la façon dont bah dont on
apprend euh plus vite peut-être
exactement
alors ça c'est SpaceX alors ça c'est
SpaceX c'est c'est avec cette fusée que
inspire 7 a été mis en orbite le 15
avril 2023 d'accord et là pareil même
chose j'ai des vis ici et vous étiez par
là vous on était ici donc vous avez le
deuxième étage avec la position des
lanceurs alors là elle peut pas se
démonter mais on a ici une vue on
regardera après à l'intérieur de la
coiffe ok donc vous avez le deuxième
étage avec là et la particularité de
leur lanceur c'est de pouvoir à un
moment récupérer cette partie donc vous
voyez ici ces éléments se déploient
ok on a des petits éléments et là ce
qu'il y a de génial c'est que on peut à
un moment lancer et la faire revenir au
sol oui on récupère
alors ça c'est pareil aussi une
particularité c'est que quand
Elon Musk et SpaceX propose cette idée
de récupérer un étage beaucoup on
considère que ce n'était pas possible ma
visiblement c'est possible vu que c'est
ce qu'ils arrivent à faire donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut qu'on ait la même chose
en France en Europe avoir des étages qui
soient récupérables et donc c'est pas
parce que ça existe d'ailleurs qu'il
faut pas le faire au contraire il faut y
aller c'est fondamental pour un élément
clé c'est ce que l'on disait c'est
l'autonomie stratégique est-ce que ce
qui arrive souvent dans les nouveaux
nouvelles façons de créer d'inventer
est-ce que par exemple les les le savoir
cactus SpaceX pour ramener
cet étage de la de la fusée c'est il le
garde pour eux c'est diffusé c'est un là
vous avez des choses avec du secret
industriels en général le savoir est
conservé alors bon je tiens quand même à
préciser dans le de Space X on sait ce
qu'on appelle une entreprise privée qui
a réussi l'exploit de mettre en orbite
des dispositifs assez rapidement mais
ils ont des investissements colossaux de
l'État américain donc ils ont eu des
appuis qui sont très importants pour y
arriver oui ils ont déjà mais il y a
aussi la pluie colossale de l'État
américain alors juste je reviens un peu
en arrière
puisque là on est là oui alors ça c'est
cette partie c'est le c'est justement le
deuxième étage donc si vous le prenez
aussi dans la main là vous avez un
moteur ici de propulsion qui va pouvoir
positionner à un moment les satellites à
une certaine altitude donc à savoir que
le premier étage à un moment la
séparation se fait au bout d'une à deux
minutes c'est au bout de quelques
minutes le premier étage se sépare du
deuxième étage et vous avez ce
dispositif lui qui va aller à plus de
500 km d'altitude voilà 500 600 700 km
d'altitude et puis à un moment une des
premières opérations c'est de séparer
ces deux éléments alors je vous laisse
faire essayer ez de les enlever alors
c'est une maquette mais imaginez
l'opération alors c'est une translation
vous allez translater puis vous allez
voir que
je peux vous aider
vous voyez que imaginez ça dans l'espace
ça veut dire quoi translate
dans ce sens
comme ça
vous êtes un
vous voyez que là on a les coiffes alors
à l'intérieur il y a généralement un
revêtement noir c'est pour éviter des
baisses en température
extérieure est blanche c'est ce qu'on
appelle un revêtement froid et puis une
fois que c'est en orbite vous êtes à 600
km d'altitude vous allez pouvoir m'en
déployer les satellites d'accord
et là vous les déployez tous
et là il y a dans notre cas de figure il
y avait 51 satellites en orbite en avril
le 15 avril 2023 ça c'est donc la tête
de de du Space X du lanceur Falcon mind
qui qui permet de dans lequel était le
inspirate exactement alors
ça
alors là on a une maquette à l'échelle
du satellite du vescussat donc vous
voyez c'est l'échelle
fois moins de fois plus gros plus gros
espace quand même enfin même si un petit
espace après on verra un élément
miniaturisé vous allez voir c'est
intéressant mais c'est incroyable nombre
d'informations
et le matériel qui est embarqué
là-dedans
on a une échelle du satellite on voit un
peu comment que ça fait il y a
énormément d'électronique des éléments
de mécanique et ici vous voyez les
antennes donc tout l'enjeu c'est de
miniaturiser un moment c'est ces
électroniques pour pouvoir faire de
l'observation
je peux vous décrire très rapidement
il y a plusieurs cartes électroniques
donc quand si vous revenez à la base on
est au niveau du du lanceur on va être
injecté donc la première chose à faire
c'est l'éjection du satellite c'est ce
qu'on voit ici si vous regardez ici on a
un satellite qui est dans un
qui est fixé vous êtes fixé au niveau du
du lanceur au niveau de cette coiffe
première opération on va utiliser des
boulons explosifs ici des boulons
explosifs qui vont éjecter un satellite
il est éjecté donc une fois qu'il est
éjecté il va se mettre en rotation
naturelle donc la première étape ça va
être de le stabiliser donc on peut
décider exactement donc on va le
stabiliser pour limiter sa rotation et
une fois qu'il est stabilisé première
opération c'est déployer ses antennes
ces antennes de communication
c'est justement ce qu'on voit au niveau
des cartes électroniques que l'on
utilise nous avons des petites bobines
magnétiques et quand on active ces
petites bobines magnétiques on va manger
un champ magnétique dans une direction
pour pouvoir le stabiliser c'est
fondamental parce que s'il tourne en
permanence c'est pas possible de
récupérer les ça va être compliqué pour
pouvoir récupérer les données donc on
doit le stabiliser une fois qu'il est
stabilisé évidemment on déploie les
antennes pour pouvoir communiquer et
ensuite l'élément clé c'est l'ordinateur
de bord nous avons un ordinateur c'est
comme un ordinateur un petit PC
l'ordinateur lui va nous permettre de
faire fonctionner le satellite d'accord
et ensuite on va avoir un étage de carte
de puissance
des batteries nous avons des batteries
comme tout le monde utilise qui sont
connectés à des générateurs solaires et
le soleil alimente les cellules solaires
qui permettent d'alimenter les batteries
ça ça nous permet d'avoir l'énergie
solaire et donc un des éléments clés
vis-à-vis de technologie spatiales aussi
c'est de pouvoir tester des cellules
solaires en orbite les cellules que nous
utilisons elles ont un rendement de 28%,
ça permet de voir comment elle
vieillisse
et ensuite une fois qu'on a eu ces
différentes cartes c'est ce qu'on voit
ici vous voyez on voit ici la partie
batterie
qui est sur la partie supérieure ici
vous voyez nous avons les batteries
qui sont simulées là les petits
magnétomètres qui permettent d'avoir un
moment la possibilité de déplacer le
satellite et puis après vous avez un
ordinateur de bord une carte fille
Descartes électroniques qui permettent
de piloter les différents instruments et
sur toutes les faces externes du
satellite nous intégrons nos détecteurs
pour faire les mesures les mesures
scientifiques et sur le haut une
centrale inertielle alors si vous
regardez de plus près
Patrice je le mets dans les mains donc
vous voyez ici les deux batteries
donc ça c'est un exemple de maquette et
là vous avez une carte de radio
communication qui permet de faire de la
transmission
alors en haut ce sont des éléments qui
permettent de blinder les systèmes qui
permettent de faire la communication et
quand vous êtes en orbite vous voyez
attention vous allez déployer ces
antennes d'accord de communication donc
ça permet de voir un moment ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui en termes de
miniaturisation incroyable
ça c'est l'ubexus et donc vous voyez ici
regardez si on vient après rajouter un
panneau solaire sur l'extérieur
c'est que là on prend bien le fixer ici
ah oui et donc l'énergie arrive par là
et sur les faces internes
on vient intégrer une multitude de
détecteurs
des cartes électroniques des capteurs de
flux donc on a mis en place toute une
série de miniaturisation
[Musique]
une fois encore une fois nous ce qui va
nous intéresser ce sont les paramètres
scientifiques mais comme on met aussi en
orbite des satellites on va avoir un
retour sur les aspects technologiques du
dispositif donc ce qu'on a déjà appris
avec
uvsq7 c'est une meilleure maîtrise du
logiciel de vol parce qu'à l'intérieur
nous avons un logiciel et des outils
d'intelligence artificielle parce que
nous avons développé les outils
d'intelligence artificielle donc on les
améliorer là on peut vous dire déjà que
pour nous c'est gagné parce que sur le
premier satellite tous les quatre jours
nous avions un redémarrage à faire du
satellite parce qu'il y avait un moment
une petite lacune sur un des codes donc
nous l'avons amélioré et là ça
fonctionne
ce qu'on a appris aussi c'est une
meilleure maîtrise des alors il y a des
événements singuliers dans l'espace
c'est à dire que vous pouvez avoir un
élément une petite particule qui vient
qui va exciter à un moment un petit
composant électronique qui fait que pour
se protéger il va y avoir un
court-circuit une augmentation au
courant et donc on redémarre le
satellite pour le protéger donc on a mis
des circuits de protection plus
performants et des électroniques plus
performantes et là dessus on s'appuie
sur les entreprises du du territoire qui
font de l'électronique avec nous alors
au début certains nous disent mais on
n'a jamais fait de spatial on leur dit
ne vous inquiétez pas on va le faire on
va vous accompagner et la connaissance
vous l'avez nous on va vous apporter la
partie qui s'appelle la spatialisation
c'est comment on protège vis-à-vis de
l'environnement donc nous avons après
cela l'enfant on a aussi après au niveau
des détecteurs qui font les mesures du
bilan radiatif de la Terre donc sur
certains on a vu que vous pouvez avoir
du bruit de temps en temps donc on a
amélioré les chaînes électroniques pour
avoir des mesures plus précises et là
vous le dites dans dans votre livre
espèce de l'espèce au service du climat
les premiers résultats que vous a
apporté
vsq7 sur sur justement la certitude du
climat en quelques mots c'est quoi si
vous voulez résumer en gros un seul
satellite un petit satellite ça
ça suffit pas parce qu'il faut savoir
qu'un gros satellite ou un satellite
traditionnel et beaucoup plus performant
va apporter beaucoup plus d'achats par
contre l'intérêt d'utiliser plusieurs
petits satellites entre eux et en
constellation ça va nous permettre de
voir ce qu'on ne peut pas voir avec un
gros satellite et ce qui va nous
intéresser nous c'est comment évolue un
moment c'est paramètres ces variables
climatiques essentielles parce qu'elle
va rien en fonction du temps donc
l'intérêt d'en avoir deux maintenant on
va pouvoir récupérer plus d'informations
pour voir quel est l'intérêt de mettre
en orbite une constellation qui va par
exemple nous permettre de détecter le
cycle dur je peux vous montrer juste
deux paramètres scientifiques
intéressants on peut s'intéresser par
exemple aux émissions de CO2 ou de
méthane et puis si on a un satellite
avec accompagné de plusieurs autres
satellites on peut détecter les
émetteurs les émetteurs de CO2 et
regarder les évolutions qui ont du temps
on peut aussi s'intéresser au profil
vertical de température au niveau de
l'atmosphère donc si on est capable
d'avoir une reproduction temps réel de
ces profils de température c'est
fondamental pour le
le climat et les modèles mais c'est
aussi intéressant pour les retraites
parce que vous voyez qu'il y a de plus
en plus de lancement et donc il y a un
intérêt à avoir ces cartographies de
température alors il y a ce livre
l'espace et de l'Union spécifique au
service du climat ce que je vous propose
parce que là on va être un peu et il
faut aidant il faut qu'on il faut pas
qu'on loupe
les deux satellites qui vont se croiser
oui c'est vrai hein donc c'est bientôt
est-ce que on va on fera une émission
spécifiquement sur ce livre
on peut terminer peut-être sur la les
dernières maquettes et puis
alors
on va monter voir dans la salle de
contrôle ouais vous allez voir en direct
le téléchargement des données et des de
satellites alors vous voyez ici là
quelques exemples de technologie qui
sont développées et de miniaturisation
allez-y pour
donc vous voyez c'est c'est ce sont des
exemples
fait tout tester
par exemple nous avons des photos diode
des photos détecteurs qui permettent de
faire des mesures de flux c'est à dire
de paramètres
climatiques peuvent nous intéresser là
il faut détecter miniaturisé
ici si vous regardez là on travaille
avec une entreprise alors qui est par
contre elle du côté de du Nord de la
France qui s'appelle captek on a des
petits éléments des détecteurs de flux
un fluxmètre ça permet de mesurer un
flux ou une température et vous voyez un
peu comment que c'est fait et ensuite ça
va être posé sur des petits miroirs
réfléchissant
qui permettent eux à un moment de
mesurer par exemple l'albédo alors je
peux vous donner au niveau climatique
qu'est-ce qui va nous intéresser vous
avez un le flux solaire incident qui
nous intéresse donc c'est le rayonnement
solaire de la réflexion du rayonnement
solaire c'est ce que l'on appelle
l'albédo d'accord et puis 3 la rémission
infrarouge de la planète donc quand ces
paramètres sont à l'équilibre la
température de la planète est constante
mais comme on injecte des gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère du CO2 du
méthane du protoxyde d'azote tous ces
gaz à effet de serre eux ils ont
tendance à rajouter une forme de
maintien c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet
de gain le principe de gaz à effet de
serre et donc la température monte le
système en déséquilibre et la planète
chauffe donc tout l'intérêt c'est de
mesurer ces variables en temps réel et
au niveau spatial pour pouvoir mieux
quantifier les effets du réchauffement
climatique et à un moment il y a un
autre paramètre qui est clé aussi c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire aussi
au niveau de l'atténuation
avec une imprimante 3D c'est la même
maquette
parce que même ouais alors c'est pas moi
on est là en train de parler de conquête
de l'espace et moi je suis un président
2030 on est dans un monde qui a qui est
en train de changer quand même alors oui
ça va vite ce qui est très important là
c'est que on s'est rendu compte et c'est
valable pour la conquête spatiale alors
il y a des banques ou des personnes qui
expliquent à l'horizon 2040 il pourrait
y avoir 4000 milliards d'investissements
dans le spatial et une des choses 4000
milliards de dollars et ce qu'il y a de
d'intéressant dans ce dans ce changement
c'est que on va se focaliser sur les
utilisateurs c'est-à-dire que à un vous
pouvez avoir des demandes
institutionnelles ou des États mais on
voit aussi apparaître des demandes des
entreprises privées et est possible que
d'ici une dizaine d'années les
investissements des entreprises privées
deviennent beaucoup plus importantes que
ceux des états alors ça a des avantages
mais ça présente des risques
et c'est vrai que vous éprouvez vous
avec
vsq5 respire ça que on pouvait que
là-bas vous êtes un organisme public de
chez des chercheurs vous êtes voilà des
enseignements supérieurs mais vous avez
prouvé travailler on peut travailler il
y a des entreprises parler de cette
entreprise du Nord il y en a
énormément on a quasiment 97% de
l'entreprise qui sont sur le territoire
on parlait des questions quand même
parce qu'on prend beaucoup de la volonté
politique
des États il y a l'Europe aussi oui où
est-ce qu'on en est où est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a une politique européenne de
l'espace alors oui il y a une politique
européenne de l'espace donc il y a vous
savez il y a une agence spatiale
européenne et puis ce qu'on appelle les
uns donc il y a une volonté de mettre en
commun des moyens alors là c'est pareil
il faut revenir dans l'histoire de la
conquête spatiale
les premiers lanceurs qui ont été faits
il y a évidemment à l'époque donc l'URSS
et les États-Unis d'Amérique on est dans
une confrontation bloc et la France ça
sert très rapidement dans cette
compétition et dans cette course à
l'espace avec ces lanceurs Véronique
puis diamant dans les années 1965 et
ensuite juste après la France à la
volonté de développer les lanceurs
européens c'est un programme qui a été
mis en place dès 1967 et c'est un
système qui s'est terminé par des échecs
il y a eu beaucoup d'échecs mes amis de
la mise en orbite des lanceurs européens
donc des Européens faisaient partie de
cette mise en œuvre
et puis à l'issue de ce programme de
lanceur de type Europa beaucoup aurait
dit bon c'est un échec on en arrête là
pas du tout les pays européens se sont
regroupés et ont eu la volonté de créer
cette agence spatiale européenne comme
j'ai expliqué précédemment en 73 en 1973
qui va donner naissance à l'état et en
PNP ça ginsency avec une volonté forte
de créer un le lanceur européen a rien
donc ça c'est un programme qui était
fort ensuite il y avait le laboratoire
en orbite space Lab et en parallèle à un
moment certains ont su parler du
programme Hermès Hermès c'était
l'équivalent de la navette spatiale
américaine mais qui était initialement
démarré par les Français et qui a été
repris par les Européens alors
malheureusement le programme a été
arrêté dans les années 1990 mais pour
moi c'est un exemple de choses qu'il
faut vraiment faire quoi il faut prier
ce genre de choses on a notre mot à dire
aussi en Europe même si comme vous le
dites on va sans doute assister à une
évolution qui fait que le privé va aussi
venir dans la conquête spatiale alors le
privé arrive on le voit arriver comme
j'expliquais il y a des avantages par
contre il y a des inconvénients les
inconvénients c'est bon le contrôle
parce que l'espace pour nous reste un
sanctuaire sacré à préserver et on ne
peut pas faire n'importe quoi bon
typiquement vous voyez que si on met une
multitude de satellites en orbite ça
peut créer des gros problèmes notamment
de coloriage
il y a des embouteillages typiquement
sur le tir de 51 satellites que l'on
vient de faire on a vu que ils étaient
tous les uns après les autres et une des
priorités c'est de pouvoir récupérer un
moi la communication vers ce satellite
mais le principal danger ce sont les
collisions si un satellite heurte un
autre satellite puis un autre satellite
il y a ce que l'on appelle l'effet
Kissinger on peut avoir une multitude de
débris dans l'espace ce qui rendrait
l'espace
inopérant et ça c'est dramatique parce
que si on perd le contrôle de l'espace
et dramatique d'un point de vue de
toutes les technologies qui nous
utilisons depuis le sol mais aussi
vis-à-vis des dangers externes comme des
météorites qui peuvent se diriger vers
la terre un croiseur un géocroiseur
voilà c'est tout l'intérêt de respecter
cet environnement et donc l'état et les
États et notamment les Nations Unies
c'est leur rôle que les différents
étapes par l'entre eux et respectent des
règles ce qu'on appelle les règles et
les lois les lois de l'espace et dans
les dans les 51
satellites qui ont été lancés 50 plus
inspire ça
vous savez ce qu'il y avait comme
satellite ou alors
oui on a une vision un peu de ce qui a
été mis en
orbite donc comme on a dit précédemment
il y avait des satellites militaires
il y a aussi des satellites comme nous
qui font de la recherche il doit y en
avoir une quinzaine ou une vingtaine
ensuite vous allez des satellites météo
des satellites commerciaux donc c'est un
peu une multitude de satellites alors le
plus gros satellite pour vous aider il
faisait environ 1000 kg d'accord donc
vous avez un gros satellite qui fait
1000 kg et puis certains satellites qui
étaient beaucoup plus petits même que ce
que l'on a fait qui pesait environ 300
400 500 g donc
inspire ça nous nous sommes à environ 3
kg d'accord
il faut qu'on monte non bon on doit
monter mais juste avant et si on allait
voir là sur ce petit rumeur 3 minutes là
ici on a quelque chose qui va nous
intéresser aussi fortement parce que le
laboratoire son objectif comme on l'a
dit c'est de de d'observer des variables
et des paramètres scientifiques on peut
le faire avec des satellites mais on
s'intéresse aussi à l'utilisation des
Rover donc là on travaille il y a une
entreprise qui s'appelle space
application service qui en Belgique on
s'intéresse à l'utilisation de ces Rover
en français on pourrait dire un
astronomie donc c'est un véhicule de
l'espace
qui doit se poser sur un moment ça peut
être la lune ça peut être mars et vous
avez vu que récemment la conquête de la
Lune a repris à nouveau
un grand grand intérêt alors pour nous
l'enjeu c'est de pouvoir utiliser ces
astres
2025 pour pouvoir positionner encore une
fois des petites charges utiles ou des
éléments et l'avantage de ces robots
c'est que vous pouvez positionner à un
moment
un satellite qui devient juste un
élément d'observation qui peut nous
permettre d'observer par exemple
la terre depuis la lune on peut aussi
observer le soleil des éclairements
solaires typiquement une des sciences
qui nous intéresse c'est par exemple
l'observation du Soleil
l'observation des éruptions solaires qui
a un moment ces éruptions solaires
peuvent se transformer en tempête
géomagnétique et c'est pareil ça a des
effets des conséquences dramatiques sur
les sociétés et je terminerai juste
ce Rover là
il est encore en étude il est
et vous espérez lancer alors on
travaille avec des entreprises qui sont
dans ce domaine et là c'est plutôt
l'horizon 2030 2030
vous voyez c'est le principe de
transport et de déplacement de
dispositif alors sur celui-ci vous avez
aussi un moment un genre de perceuse qui
permet de percer le sol et de pouvoir
récupérer la nature des gaz
et tu des atmosphères planétaires c'est
exceptionnel et voilà oui on a sur la
photo là enfin une fois terminé ça donne
ça quoi alors oui ça c'est une vie vue
d'artiste avec nos partenaires de la
société space application et voilà ils
font du vraiment du bon travail quoi
on a vu à peu près à peu près les
éléments Patrick j'ai l'impression que
le satellite va passer il faut y aller
il faut y aller
on monte et ben on va prendre la
récupération des données allez
alors là si on se revoit sur l'écran là
si vous regardez là on est en train de
faire un moment là le téléchargement des
données du satellite uvez ce que ça qui
passe en premier et donc on a la
descente de données depuis le satellite
vers le sol donc c'est un signal audio
et le signal audio va être transformé en
données en données brute et ensuite on
va obtenir des données physiques
commandent des satellites exactement
donc nous sommes dans le centre de
contrôle commande satellite des Yvelines
qu'on a mis en place et puis on est en
train de contrôler de satellites
sont à la suite là si vous venez vous
avez un petit zoom on peut voir ici
aussi là vous voyez les deux vont même
se croiser
vous les voyez
ok donc inspire ça 7 arrive du Sud et
uvez cussa t'arrive du Nord et ils vont
se croiser au-dessus de Guyancourt
mais mais
les deux alors le inspire ça tu es à 508
km d'altitude et usqsa tu es environ 530
km d'altitude
donc là vous voyez le signal est très
bon on voit une belle bande
[Rires]
ce qui est ce qui est positif puis vous
voyez ici là le décodage des trams en
direct
ils envoient les données là
et que vous allez traduire vous en
donner physique donner physique pour
avoir des paramètres scientifiques alors
là si vous regardez ici on les a aussi
sur nos outils on a inspire ça là qui
est au dessus de l'Afrique en ce moment
donc il est en train de monter et
ensuite on va avoir un moment à partir
du moment où on le verra
au dessus de la Méditerranée il va
commencer à envoyer des informations
vers la station sol qui situe ici à
Guyancourt à quelle vitesse il se
déplace alors si vous regardez les
paramètres c'est plusieurs kilomètres
par seconde
sur un QR code donc là la bascule vers
l'autre satellite est en train de se
faire
donc vous avez l'antenne là-bas si vous
filmez et de l'extérieur qui est en
train de se déplacer qui pointe le
deuxième satellite
c'est ce que vous voyez à gauche là vous
voyez de satellite
et puis donc il est en train de se
positionner vers le satellite suivant
pour récupérer les données
donc vous voyez là on a récupéré ici
tram en direct nous avons la dernière
heure donc ici là on a les trams qui
sont téléchargées par rapport à inspire
sat si je vais regarder du côté de
uvsqat par exemple voilà et là il a il a
envoyé l'ordre
vous voyez maintenant le téléchargement
du deuxième satellite donc ce que vous
voyez c'est unique c'est unique dans le
sens où on a une région qui a quand même
de satellites en opération en même temps
et ça en France on est les seuls donc et
vous avez vu que les deux
téléchargements se sont fait à la suite
et là c'est André Jean nous avons un
très bon signal
[Musique]
donc là on est en train de télécharger
la trame et alors nous avec nos outils
évidemment on peut le regarder ici en
direct et vous allez voir que on va
avoir l'augmentation du nombre de
paquets ici qui vont commencer à
s'amplifier
et donc on regarde en parallèle des
paramètres comme la tension on peut
aussi regarder ce qui s'est passé les 7
derniers jours donc vous voyez bien que
la température du satellite est comprise
entre -50 et plus 50 degrés Celsius
la tension du satellite et autour de 16
volts
et puis nous avons la température
- 50 + 50 c'est quoi c'est la
température de
c'est là où il est ou c'est le satellite
lui-même l'espace l'espace froid il est
environ 3 Kelvin ce qui veut dire moins
de 169 degrés Celsius OK et donc le
satellite lui est dans un environnement
très froid donc on utilise des solutions
pour pouvoir le mettre à une certaine
température déjà la dissipation des
cartes électroniques donc en général un
satellite est testé à 20 degrés Celsius
en laboratoire le cas idéal c'est
d'avoir un satellite qui est en
permanence ça va degrés Celsius c'est
la température ambiante bon et c'est
quasiment impossible parce que comme
j'ai expliqué l'environnement de
l'espace froid c'est moins 269 degrés
Celsius environ et puis on a aussi le
flux le flux du soleil en vis-à-vis donc
c'est environ 1400 watts par mètre carré
de flux 1400 watts sur 1 m² et ensuite
on a aussi le rayonnement de la planète
donc tout ça fait un moment une forme
d'équilibre donc grosso modo quand le
satellite va être face au soleil il va
chauffer donc là on va être aux
alentours de 50 degrés et ensuite à
d'autres périodes on se retrouve en
éclipse c'est-à-dire derrière la terre
et là il va être plus froid donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a ce qu'on appelle un
cycle ainsi que et donc on évolue entre
-40 et plus 40 degrés Celsius il y a pas
de risque pour enfin tout ce qui est
embarquer les les
l'intelligence artificielle oui il y a
un risque et donc l'espace c'est quelque
chose d'hostile c'est quelque chose de
d'agressif donc on a des radiations des
protons du rayonnement du rayonnement
solaire mais aussi du cyclage en
température comme vous pouvez l'observer
donc si on n'arrive pas à valider les
technologies embarquées on perd un
satellite
donc avoir un satellite opérationnel
c'est quelque chose qui est pas si
simple que cela et c'est pour cela qu'à
Guyancourt aussi une autre particularité
c'est que nous avons une plateforme de
test la plateforme de test de Guyancourt
qui permet de faire tous les essais de
validation dans satellite donc on
vérifie en température le fonctionnement
du satellite on fait des essais de
vibrations pour vérifier que ça ne casse
pas le lancement et ainsi de suite alors
il nous manque encore quelques moyens
comme par exemple des cages un écoïde
pour vérifier le comportement
électromagnétique donc là nous avons des
coopérations avec l'ONERA pour faire ce
genre de test avec le Centre national
d'études spatiale on vérifie le
comportement magnétique donc on fait des
tests c'est ce qui vous différencie de
ce spetlave alors il faut leur test en
dit non on a vu avec la fusée non de
Leon musk
nous vous pouvez faire l'essai en direct
en gros et on voit mieux alors
évidemment ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
que de faire des cerveaux mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a ces deux techniques non
nous on est dans la même méthode que
c'est à dire que vous avez été lancé
cela
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que il y
a ceux qui font de la théorie et qui
font toujours de la théorie il y a
jamais il y a jamais quelque chose qui
partira il y a bon nous on est à
laboratoire de recherche expérimental
donc on fait à la fois
de l'étude théorique mais aussi de
l'étude expérimentale d'accord donc à
partir du moment où nous faisons des
développements instrumentaux il faut
aussi faire des tests il faut accepter
l'échec
on peut avoir à un moment quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne pas et rebondir bon
dans le cas de Starship qui est parti
bon ce qu'ils ont fait c'est pour ma
part c'est exceptionnel donc on a une
fusée qui fait plus de 130 mètres de
haut avec une multitude de moteur on a
un engin spatial qui est colossal qui a
fait quand même 4 minutes de vol donc le
seul problème qu'ils ont eu c'est la
séparation de des différents étages de
la fusée donc ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
exceptionnel et donc ils ont appris ils
ont appris
exactement il y a une multitude de
paramètres qui ont été récupérés pour
pouvoir faire la chose c'est pareil pour
nous et pour vous aussi vous apprenez
aussi
on récupère de l'information et des
données et puis typiquement du premier
satellite au deuxième satellite nous
avons amélioré des choses entre les
VSQ et personne il y a voilà il y a eu
des progrès qui a été fait quoi c'est ça
oui exactement là là on nous on peut
dire vis-à-vis par exemple du logiciel
de vol embarqué il y a des choses qui
ont été améliorées voilà donc là je
pense qu'on est peut-être à la fin du
premier ou début de téléchargement on va
demander à André Jean
alors tu as récupéré beaucoup de tram là
je pense
exactement alors le signal est assez
puissant là je trouve
le moins puissant début de passage et il
était bien après d'accord et au niveau
de l'élévation on est à quelle élévation
en ce moment là
donc on est à 49 degrés d'élévation vous
voyez et là on est déjà le satellite
donc vous avez vu il se déplace à
environ 6 km par seconde en Afrique il
est des là il est déjà bon inspire ça
lui maintenant il est au niveau bah il
se dirige vers le Groenland et vers le
pôle Nord et puis ben
UVs Q5 lui vous avez c'est complètement
dessert et là il est actuellement
environ au niveau du Cameroun c'est
incroyable alors on dit bonjour à nos
amis camerounais un grand bonjour à nos
amis camerounais voilà c'est incroyable
donc vous voyez les déplacements et donc
là on a la position du soleil aussi donc
le Zénith 12h donc avec ces outils on a
automatiquement la position des
satellites et on peut anticiper beaucoup
de choses et ils sont toujours mouvement
les satellites
quand par exemple on a un avion ou un
dispositif qui met en orbite le
référentiel c'est toujours la terre ce
qu'on appelle un référentiel Galilée
donc quand un satellite est environ 500
km d'altitude sur une orbite polaire il
fait environ 14 à 15 tours par jour donc
on peut pas l'arrêter donc la seule
façon de pouvoir entre guillemets le
ralentir ou le freiner quand vous prenez
une orbite vous avez donc la planète
Terre un satellite et à un moment on
passe au plus près de la terre quand on
passe au plus près de la Terre c'est ce
qu'on appelle le PSG
normalement on doit être sûr c'est à
dire que la la descente doit être sûr
pour pouvoir récupérer 100% de données
mais il peut y avoir des problèmes
typiquement on peut avoir un souci au
niveau matériel de la réception de
données on peut avoir un potentiel souci
au niveau du satellite qui a basculé sur
un mode recettes il a redémarré et puis
ben multitude de problèmes peuvent
exister comme par exemple aussi la
qualité du ciel quand la qualité du ciel
est très très mauvaise parfois ça peut
aussi générer quelques perturbations
voilà donc là on est vraiment vu que la
météo n'est pas très bonne c'est pour ça
alors donc on est dans ce centre de
contrôle et comment tu as des satellites
et puis il y a beaucoup de jeunes des
jeunes c'est l'avenir qui sont pas des
étudiants non il y a des gens qu'on a
embauché alors il y a des gens qui
arrivent des jeunes étudiants alors vous
avez des collégiens un collégiens voilà
collégien et l'espace c'est c'est une
passion
un peu donc on a aussi Louis Louis qui
travaille avec nous et il a embau
exactement je suis assistant ingénieur
électronicien au l'Atmos et je travaille
sur un simulateur d'environnement pour
les futurs nano satellite voilà alors là
là c'est Nicolas kenyard qui travaille
aussi ici qui a un emploi et qui a
réalisé l'opération il peut rapidement
dire ce qu'il a fait oui voilà donc là
j'ai assisté à André Jean pas pouvoir
bien réceptionner en gros les données du
satellite voilà OK et puis on a Angel en
gel minet qui fait un stage chez nous un
deuxième stage de cinquième année de
l'ESTACA une école qui est peut-être un
peu de dire un petit mot de l'Estaque ce
qu'elle fait alors je suis en dernière
année c'est une école qui est
spécialisée dans les transports et moi
je suis plutôt du coup dans la partie
spatiale et là je travaille avec Louis
aussi sur le simulateur d'environnement
spatial
qui est une apprenti de l'école
d'optique et puis les deux on va les
embaucher à l'issue de leur de leur
stage ou de leur apprentissage
donc moi je travaille actuellement sur
le prochain nano satellite et sur les
moyens de test optique qu'on va utiliser
pour les instruments et puis une
nouvelle arrivée qui peut se présenter
rapidement là c'est une surprise mais en
direct
et travailler sur les capteurs de vin
qui ont soit embarqués sur l'équipe 7 et
parce que parfois on dit ça on parlait
des lones musk tout à l'heure et il y a
aussi c'est lui l'idée peut-être de chez
certains l'idée de trouver un autre
endroit pour vivre
ça c'est des choses qu'elle vous
réfléchissez aussi
je pense ce sont plus des questions
existentialistes je pense que tout le
monde doit se poser cette question parce
que bon pour ma part il y a qu'une
planète c'est la planète Terre on se
focalise nous sur le plan a l'objectif
de nos
satellite c'est justement enfin de de de
d'étudier notamment le réchauffement
climatique va les raisons exactement
donc c'est pour améliorer la vie sur la
terre alors c'est ce sont des
démonstrateurs qui permettent
d'envisager un moment la mise en place
d'orbi de constellations de satellites
pour pouvoir avoir évidemment la mesure
de ces paramètres essentiels mais pour
répondre à la première question oui on
réfléchit aussi à développer d'autres
solutions pour envisager potentiellement
un exode alors pour ma part c'est pas
une option actuellement mais il faut
l'envisager
il faut l'envisager donc c'est pas
complètement aberrant
bravo à tous c'est bien c'est c'est
génial de voir des justement comme ça
par l'expérimentation par le par la
recherche et puis par le l'inconnu aussi
il y a de ça il y a l'inconnu et puis
bon moi ce qui me fait plaisir
parce que vous savez la bon on lance un
satellite quand on dit que à un moment
il faut aussi une part de chance les
gens ça les surprend mais développa un
programme de A à Z et avoir un satellite
qui est là-haut et opérationnel il y a
énormément d'obstacles alors des
observent cette technologie
scientifiques
administratif et bon vous savez aussi
qu'à un moment quand on combine
l'ensemble on peut avoir aussi quelque
chose qui ne marche pas donc moi
j'insiste qu'à être très important c'est
que il faut savoir accepter l'échec
c'est quelque chose de fondamental pour
pouvoir rebondir et puis à un moment va
faire mieux et puis il faut un peu de
patience parce que il faut être très
patient inspire ça de lancer le 15 avril
il aurait dû être lancé un petit peu
avant il y a eu des problèmes même
peut-être on l'a dit je sais pas
peut-être de le confirmer mais peut-être
que la tension qui a eu entre les
États-Unis et la Chine a peut-être joué
un rôle dans le report du lancement
ouais c'est possible après ce qui s'est
passé bon normalement ce lancement
devait avoir lieu en janvier
c'est ce qui est prévu par exemple deux
ans à l'avance et puis après bah
maintenir des délais de ce type fait que
c'est difficile donc il a été décalé et
reporté puis reporté au 1er avril puis
ça a été décalé au neuf et vous avez
suivi un peu alors ce qui s'est passé
pour un des report c'est qu'à un moment
ils peuvent intégrer au dernier moment
des satellites militaires qui ont une
évocation militaires ou défense
typiquement nous sur les faces
d'intégration de l'ensemble des
satellites on était sur une face entre
guillemets cachée vous avez pu le voir
pendant le lancement donc on est sur une
face où il y avait des satellites
militaires donc en général on est voilà
et ensuite le le dernier décalage qu'on
a eu donc du du 11 au 13 puis au 15 et
ainsi de suite parce qu'on est parti de
15 avril à un moment on est plus pris
par les aspects liés à la météo
voilà et à des risques quand un
satellite part si les conditions météo
sont mauvaises on peut avoir un moment
un lanceur qui échoue donc voilà
c'est génial en tout cas on a trouvé au
bon moment je sais pas mais vous avez
été parfait vous êtes arrivés pile-poil
à l'heure qu'il fallait bon vous êtes
fier de d'être là
bravo c'est bien et bravo enfin vous
Mustapha parce que c'est vrai que ça
fait partie aussi de vos de votre
personnalité de vous la former des
jeunes d'attirer des jeunes dans cette
recherche un peu
moi je pense que c'est c'est essentiel
parce que
l'espace c'est quelque chose mon qui
fait rêver beaucoup de monde dont moi
bon vous savez qu'il y en a qui ont été
baignés par le programme Apollon de
conquête spatiale avec le premier homme
qui a marché sur la Lune en
1969 et puis là on est dans une forme de
Nouvelle-Zélande ou l'espace attire et
puis alors il y a quand même une
confrontation entre ceux qui veulent
faire de l'argent gagner beaucoup
d'argent et puis nous les rêveurs on est
un peu les rêveurs à imaginer un espace
différent et moi je pense bon là vous
voyez il y a une deux trois quatre cinq
six donc vous avez aussi un cannelle
Angèle Nicolas Louis et puis Liam bah
peut-être que eux ils iront une de oui
c'est possible d'être ou que indécise va
nous faire quelque chose de génial dans
les 15 gouvernants 20 années qui
viennent et puis ça c'est intéressant
parce que là ils sont sur un petit
événement particulier aujourd'hui mais
dans 20 ans ils vont peut-être nous
fabriquer une nouvelle fusée un nouveau
Rover ou bien un marché sur sur Mars je
ne sais pas c'est ça qui intéressant
avec le spatial le temps est le temps
est enfin ce qu'on presse un peu c'est
vrai quand on pense pour le premier
avion et le concours il y a 60 ans quoi
donc dans quelques années on peut penser
qu'il y aura des progrès absolument
énorme quoi alors oui alors par contre
il faut aussi que les connaissances
peut-être plus fortes aussi alors il y a
une connaissance il y a un autre
paramètre important c'est ce que l'on
appelle le colbertisme high-tech qui
vient de Colbert c'est qu'à l'époque à
un moment on peut envisager ou imaginer
de développer des programmes pour la
grandeur d'une nation et il y a
automatiquement des retombées alors le
colbertisme high tech donc moderne vous
avez vu que la France a quand même fait
le TGV c'est quelque chose de génial
pour moi vous avez aussi
le Concorde qui a un grand programme
un moment il y a eu le Minitel qui a pas
eu oui
vous avez aussi les premiers ordinateurs
français vous avez à rien rien de génial
donc la question là c'est pour l'horizon
2025 2030 qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
génial et ça c'est important pour cette
nouvelle génération c'est quel type de
programme on peut mettre en avant qui va
donner un moment une perspective sur les
25 années qui viennent et puis on a tous
les je pense tous les moyens
intellectuels on les a après il faut les
moyens financiers c'est parfois un peu
plus compliqué mais j'entends ça dire la
volonté et la volonté il faut de la
volonté
ce qu'on appelle l'institutionnalisation
par le haut c'est un moment
politique
nous on est moi je suis convaincu que on
doit prendre un moment
une position en l'espace forte pour dire
que l'espace doit rester quelque chose
qui appartient à l'humanité et l'espace
doit être préservé c'est ce qu'on
appelle un sanctuaire naturel à
préserver qui appartient à l'humanité là
où la France peut potentiellement se
positionner c'est pour dire voilà on va
mettre en avant des constellations
satellites pour pouvoir récupérer
beaucoup de données pour avoir un état
de santé de la planète Terre donc si on
a senti de la planète Terre c'est
quelque chose de vraiment bien et c'est
le but des satellites que vous avez
alors c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire un
petit échelle il faut qu'on reste
vraiment modeste et puis essayer de
créer une impulsion ça fait partie de ce
travail qui est immense exactement
merci merci à tous bravo et vous
continuez à rester connecté
[Musique]